[Music]
a teapot
that was advertised by jcpenney has been
the center of controversy because people
were saying that teapot looks like adolf
hitler
i'm not making this up and i have to see
say i have seen the side by side
comparisons
they kind of have a point this is
absolutely real there's hitler
and there's the teapot
yes i'm not making this up
here is head of product acquisitions for
jcpenney phil hermann and he's going to
tell his side of the story
hi everyone hi everybody
hi conan thank you okay now mr herman
lots of people are upset about the
teapot's resemblance to to
hitler yes we feel terrible we want to
assure everyone it was purely
coincidental
but jcpenney has plenty of quality
inoffensive products anyone would love
want to see some of them
i think we'd love to see some j.c
penney's
okay how about this the new jcpenney
bavarian pasta pot
with with a conveniently located gravy
ladle brush
that wipes away impurities i'm sorry
i'm sorry sorry i have to say that looks
like adolf hitler again kind of well
i'm not seeing that at all but fine i'll
show you something that looks nothing
like hitler
it's our brand new interlocking s
electric fan
you can't tell but it exterminates hot
air
and how about our new storm cleaner
robotic vacuum
vacuum sucking octo clean that's great
you know
that's german for thanks for listening
all right sir
you're not hoping your case well agree
to disagree
i'll just leave you with this tasteful
jcpenney code rack for your home
so long everybody
[Applause]
you're welcome jcpenney